ladies and gentlemen it's my pleasure to
introduce Deborah Renee del maguey let's
have a big applause good evening I am
the director of the Charles Simon Centre
for adult life and learning at the 92nd
Street Y as Gail said Deborah at Nadel
Magee and I'd like to welcome you to our
season of great minds don't think alike
all of us have been deeply shaken by the
terrorist attacks of September 11th in
keeping with our mission of serving the
community by offering a forum for ideas
we have added a number of lectures panel
discussions and interviews relevant to
our New World Order one of these events
is a special edition of Roger Rosenblatt
and Friends a New York state of mind
featuring Ed Koch Alan Alda
Joel Grey Jane Pauley Norah
Efrain Vartan Gregorian Frank McCourt
and other special guests this event will
benefit the 92nd Street Y September 11th
response fund which helps us to provide
vitally important mental health
emotional support housing assistance and
employment services as well as
scholarship assistance to children and
adults impacted by the disaster and if
you would like to make a contribution to
the 92nd Street Y September 11th
response fund please contact our
development office thank you
at tonight's program biological weapons
and America's secret war has been
sponsored by our good friends Barnes and
Noble we wish to thank Barnes & Noble
for their continued support of our
lecture program a moderator this evening
Robert Krulwich special correspondent
with ABC News appears regularly on night
and hosted the network's 1999 series
brave new world his work on the PBS TV
series frontline has won Robert Krulwich
Emmy George Polk and DuPont awards for
programs on subjects from campaign
reform to the Internet our esteemed
panel consists of Judith Miller senior
writer at the New York Times Steven
Engelberg senior investigative foreign
news editor for The New York Times
William broad senior science writer for
The New York Times and Jerome h-power
who served as the first director of New
York City's Office of Emergency
Management and he's got a very long
resume which you'll learn about
throughout the evening following their
discussion you will be able to ask
questions of our guests and please write
your questions on the cards that you did
receive as you entered the hall and then
they will be collected by our Usher's
throughout the program at the end of the
evening you will be able to purchase
copies of the new book germs biological
weapons and America's secret war Unseld
in the Hall of Mirrors and the authors
Judith Miller Steven Engelberg and
William broad will be signing copies of
the books in the art gallery right next
door to this room ladies and gentlemen
now please join me in welcoming mr.
Robert Krulwich thank you
yeah I guess we've taken care of the
introductions just so you know who's who
geographically judy obviously directly
to my left Jerry to her left Stephen to
his left bill on the far end so having
just Fred German which is a the books of
the three guys wrote three two men in
the lady wrote one of the themes one of
the mid principle themes of the book is
captured in a remark by a fellow named
Matthew meselson he's a Harvard
biologist Steve me ask you he says the
best thing that a wealthy nation on
earth can do is to keep war expensive
what does he mean by that well I mean I
think one of the striking things that we
found in doing this research bill and
myself of both how sort of background in
thinking about nuclear weapons and if
you want to make an atom bomb and you're
a nation there's this enormous number of
Hoops that you have to jump through you
have to get the uranium you have to
create an industrial infrastructure you
have to get the science right you do a
lot of testing you know it's billions
and billions of dollars to do what we
did at Los Alamos in 1945 to get a germ
weapon is a far far easier proposition
the costs are much lower the real thing
that you need is expertise is knowing
how to do it now that means that it's
easily within the grasp of a far broader
group of people than you might expect
and what meselson was saying is let's
try to lock this thing up before we get
to the point we're at today which is
there for $100,000 $200,000 you know and
a bit of expertise you can go out and
make the most horrific weapons
imaginable so Jerry are we now at the
stage where something like waging
serious warfare is now a game that a
whole lot of new players can play
essentially the entry cost of going to
war has just come way down well I think
you have to look at the perspective
getting biological weapons to a
weaponized State it's not as easy as it
sounds getting biologically weaponized
means
so that you can do something any handed
into a high quality a state where you've
got concentrated anthrax or if we look
at just take anthrax getting it into a
weaponized State is not as easy as it
sounds getting biological agents and
getting them to a point where you can
use them is not that difficult what
about the power of when you close your
eyes and imagine an atomic bomb going
off you see an explosion that covers a
discreet the pretty vast piece of the
the target compared bill what dropping
an atomic bomb on Manhattan and dropping
something germ like on or about
Manhattan what's the difference can they
be equally powerful depending depending
on the germ it can be more devastating
than a nuclear weapon especially if
you're thinking about something
contagious that spreads you know from
person to person to person anthrax is is
nice in a way because it just sits there
if you get it it doesn't go to the next
person the the strangest thing of all
about German weapons is that they're
silent you know when a nuke goes off
there's this enormous concussive blast
like that radiates out and devastates
stuff within a discrete area germs are
silent you know when the agent goes out
it's it rise on the wind they can be
quite fickle and that's one of the
drawbacks and it's also one of the hopes
because they are difficult to
disseminate correctly and well germ the
germ weapon people that we got to know
in the course of writing this book
describes some of the difficulties for
instance of attacking large cities
because of the micro meteorology and the
fickle winds around skyscrapers and that
kind of stuff it's a it's it's difficult
to pull off in the in the in the outside
area but it's silent you don't know and
you don't have until people start
pouring into the emergency room or until
we get to the state where
have good germ detectors that can tell
you the day you've been hit there's this
terrible sense of unknowing the book
begins with a an attack I guess it's a
biological attack it it takes place a
little town called Dallas Oregon Judy
and it features but one Shree Rajneesh a
woman named Sheila and another woman who
goes by the nickname nurse Mengele in
other words it's just not an attractive
group of people could you describe what
happened there like a little Cosby 1984
in the Dallas and it is a breathtakingly
beautiful place and that's why this
Indian guru wanted to settle there and
he and his followers did and they
attracted about three or four thousand
people which was a lot and they all wore
red and they worked like crazy and
believed in free sex and so as you can
imagine they were controversial within
the community said I wanted to expand
and the locals didn't want them to
expand so they decided in the best of
American traditions that they would get
rid of they Wasco County Planning Board
they could expand and they would do this
by making everyone very sick so they
couldn't vote and this was actually the
first biological weapons attack a mass
attack on the United States they
succeeded in making these people sick
about seven hundred and fifty people by
sprinkling Salmonella in the salad bars
and coffee jars and things of
restaurants all the way along the
highway and they just wanted to see if
they could do it in advance of the
election and they did and it took more
than a year to discover that this was
not a natural
break of Salmonella but that this was in
fact an attack actually it took the the
bhagwan shree rajneesh himself accusing
his own folks it's actually right mister
god that's what bhagwan shree translated
sir god
there was a fight within the cult and
basically the cult imploded and he stood
up at a news conference a year after the
actual attack and accused some of his
followers of getting carried away and
making people sick and that gave the FBI
what they needed at that point to go
into the Rajneeshpuram as it was called
with search warrants and they found the
back troll discs which had contained
salmonella and it was a perfect match
with the Salmonella that had made the
people of Oregon since the year before
and voila the mystery was solved but
even after that you would have thought
that this was kind of a wake-up call for
America but it wasn't because the health
authorities the CDC that did the
investigation said you know this is
really very easy to do and we don't want
to alarm people so let's not write about
it let's not do a thorough
epidemiological study let's not publish
it right now in fact it wasn't published
until 1997 so what should have been a
wake-up call didn't wake anyone up at
all one of the more shocking parts of
this is that the the Sheila and nurse
Mengele when they were looking for the
Salmonella I didn't realize this Steve
but you can in those days anyway you
could just call up any number of
laboratories around the country and they
although I guess WVW are scientific
which is a company in Seattle and a
company that gets very often mention in
your book called the American type
culture collection well it wasn't just
in those days it actually went on in
1984 is Judy points out they were too
Salmonella a few years later some Iraqi
front companies who
you know a nice selection of anthrax
weird where is this place this sits in
Virginia J Mascis
I knew it has a catalog and you look and
you say I'd like a little botulism like
oh this meat to be feared let's look
let's feel a little bit fair why not as
a the it's very useful in science to be
able to have a reference library of
strains and to be able to order specific
strains for research this has a real
purpose the issue is not you know oh my
goodness there are germ banks on earth
which researchers use the issue is what
kind of controls are out there to
prevent your true nut cases from
ordering whatever they want and through
the reason you know one of the main
reasons we've succeeded in crushing
infectious disease is because
researchers have been exchanging these
strains and getting them out of banks
and studying how to get a leg up on
tuberculosis or plague or whatever it is
it's it's the main reason we live to an
average age of you know whatever it is
seventy or you know 80 years but a
possible argument why we might be in
danger of not being able to live to that
natural length is the following story
from your book the CIA publishes a paper
in 1988 and says let's not send any more
of these terrible germs to Iraq for x
y&z reasons three months later an order
arrives from Iraq and Baghdad at the
Americans high culture collection it's
filled on September 29 1988 three months
after the CIA warning what there were no
controls I mean anybody could I think
you have to have some kind of customs
punished if you remember Larry Wayne
Harris was
of a crackpot scientist that though he
was a microbiologist it was kind of a
right-wing kind of guys extremists that
back in the mid 90s was arrested for
having various biological agents at home
which he got from the same place do you
or never and it was really at that point
in time that they began looking at
putting controls in place the CDC was
responsible for controlling the shipment
of these things enforcement is still
difficult it's weird to me that it takes
an American right-wing microbiologist to
create the enough of a problem here
you've got Iraq ordering and ordering
and ordering the CIA says don't don't
don't and off go the orders well and
Jerry yeah five minutes it's passing
strange I mean that particular document
that he's mentioning not only says Iraq
is ordering it says Iraq is watering it
from eighty CC so you would have thought
that perhaps one official or analyst or
expert a bureaucrat and one agency could
have pick up the phone and call somebody
and said you know I know there's no
rules on this but maybe just on this one
we don't have to do this you know you're
in the federal government a bit these
days why doesn't somebody do that well I
think that that there's an enormous
disconnect in the federal can under
statement is also here even though yeah
the the agencies historically have not
talked to each other and they
particularly have not talked to each
other about this issue a lot of people a
lot of the agencies a lot of agency
heads did not see this as as a
significant problem up until September
11th we had trouble getting people
engaged in this issue and as Judy he'll
tell you we've we've been down there
testifying for six or seven years trying
to get to us an attention focused on
just how serious biological agents could
be you know the poor man's atom bomb and
we really up until 1998 when we briefed
President Clinton and I've got to tell
you he was very engaged on the issue and
he really tried everything he could to
get the federal agencies focus we could
not get Donna shillelagh focused on this
issue one bit Janet Reno was very
engaged but we the agencies did not talk
I think that Tom ridges rolled to try
and get the agencies together to get the
agency's focus is going to be a real
challenge I think I think that he now
has the backing of the White House to
get it done but memos like this to float
around and the CIA might not have been
talking to the FBI the CIA has no
domestic role so in order to effect this
kind of thing they would have had to
have talked to the FBI who would have
had to it'd have talked to American
tissue culture and said maybe we don't
want to ship this stuff to around the
likelihood of that happening was pretty
small but I mean 89 they did some export
controls so even though it was easy to
get them in the United States
you couldn't ship them to Iraq without
special waivers internet so once however
bill once you you order these these
broad stock materials is it easy to I'm
like what do you do to grow more of them
you get some from Virginia and you want
to have many is it hard to go from some
to many it it doesn't take a whole lot
and especially if you're making a small
quantity you know you can do this in a
laboratory at any of the great
universities right around us actually
you guys in the book describe a sort of
a Nevada experiment that went on with
describe what happened one of you what
happened there actually there I was
there this was a one of the bio defense
activities that our government was doing
and not telling anyone about in fact
they also didn't tell the CIA they were
doing it this was the Pentagon that was
going to build an off-the-shelf
biological weapon
lab to see if they could do it from kind
of off-the-shelf parts and all the shelf
meaning whatever's around no hardware
stores I'm getting home people enter
home details they bought a used
fermenter from Germany fermenters
they're used for lots of things for
making yogurt to beer their standard
item these days and so in the middle of
the Nevada Test Site which is also
pretty weird they decided they would
just take a Jim Nate what had been a
kind of rec hall very small room
actually about this song as the size of
the stage and they would assemble all
these things was a team of Detroit
people that's defense Threat Reduction
agency and they wouldn't tell the CIA
about it and they would see if the CIA
could detect these purchases well the
CIA didn't detect the purchases the
plant was assembled in less than a year
it cost less than a million dollars to
put together substantially less and no
one knew it was there a detective its
activity and it made perfect
weapons-grade simulants for anthrax in
little vials and in the Nova that you're
going to guys are going to be on coming
up there you are sitting in what looks
like some kind of I don't know little
ordinary just a house along the road
there's nothing beat nothing special
nothing conspicuous nothing obvious and
and I have been to a lot of new of
biological facilities all over the
former Soviet Union would never have
picked out this you know corrugated like
building it was the place where the
atomic weapons people used to come just
before the test to kind of do their work
and then they fall back here and and
there was nothing about this pale yellow
building kind of cheap 1950's
construction that would have told you
hey you know they're making biological
simulants in this building and it was
frightening because it brought home to
me how relatively
it would be to do this without detection
and that was the point of the
government's experiment that's why I
wanted to do it and it succeeded
astonishingly well okay so we got easy
to get
we got easy to grow before I get too
easy to fabricate which is something
Terry's been warning me about let me ask
you about the Iraqi materially Iraqis
did did some kind of biological research
and I guess grew something then we went
to war against them is what they grew
still around as far as we know or is it
going away clarify a couple of things
about this and then walk to mystery
which is where you end up
it's amazing how sort of an expert the
American people have become on the
subject of anthrax we just think this is
a very arcane thing before the war the
Iraqis made a liquid anthrax which they
put into shells and tried to figure out
how they could you know use an airplane
to disperse it they did some experiments
with that and it was pretty nasty stuff
but it was liquid he was 2,200 gallons
of yeah great it's like a swimming pool
worth of anthrax oh yes and and other
stuff too they also made botulinum which
is a toxin very very you know nasty
substance that will definitely kill you
if you come into contact with it they
did not before the Gulf War succeed as
far as we know we don't know by any
means everything and making the kind of
powdered anthrax we see in these letters
however after the war the United Nations
comes in they look around they finally
figure out that all this stuff is there
in liquid form the Iraqis say oh we've
destroyed it well we're the records well
trust us we lost those two there's a lot
of conversation back and forth about
this and not everybody is convinced that
everything was destroyed then on top of
that they went to a factory and
discovered that the Iraqis were making a
bio pesticide stuff you'd spray on your
roses to kill you know caterpillars
which happens to be a close relative of
anthrax and normally you make this stuff
in a certain kind of size that it floats
the ground and lands on the plants you
know let's say 100 microns but these
guys are making their bio pesticide at
about a 5 micron size
we now all know is the size that you see
in these letters that of course is
worthless for biopesticide because it
float away go up in the air and nobody
ever quite figured out why they were had
a whole factory to make this 5 micron
biopesticide so the working assumption
is a they may or may not have destroyed
their liquid anthrax B they could well
have powdered anthrax and C they
certainly know how to make it so that's
kind of where we are as far as we know
which isn't necessarily okay we're
moving on then so you need to get easy
to grow now easy to fabricate the
anthrax that went to Senator Daschle is
it American in some sense of its design
or bill it is an American strain a
domestic strain of anthrax I mean when
you get below the species level you get
lots of differentiation there's about 93
different strains of anthrax the the one
in the - whole letter and in all the
letters it turns out is ames which was
isolated some time in ames iowa at the
Iowa State University in its there's a
debate whether the 40s 50s 60s we're not
sure but it's something you can come
upon an anthrax for and look in and and
trace it back to one did cow from Ames
Iowa or yes yeah they have distinctive
DNA signatures and it just screams you
know the this is you know what it is
also an even more troubling aspect of
the daschle powder was that it had
silica in it to take away the
electrostatic charge and to make it very
fluffy and light and to rise into the
air easily the easier to get in deer
lungs which was a trademark of we're
told of the the US weapons program so on
to scores this this has on those two
issues it smells American in some
respects not only does it smell American
but you actually in the book described
the fellow who turned the anthrax into a
dry flaky kind of non clumpy powder
right whose name is Bill Patrick and
when he leaves Fort Dietrich this is an
amazing little piece of business his
business
did you describe his business type oh
boy he built Patrick first is a is a
great I think a great American and is as
and as a serious scientist but he also
like many of these people have a loved
black humor and his card has the grim
reaper with the hood and the scythe and
germs coming down and what's what's the
phrase bio warfare oh yeah and this dark
figure is casting out the term germs
yeah our American designer yeah he also
makes home movies and demonstrates in
his home movies that he has designed an
anthrax which once it falls down on the
ground can be lightly lofted up again
right right you like this guy later son
buyer beware
yeah I think bill Patrick is a good man
who is he he has been working for a long
long time ever since he quit the army in
86 to try to raise the federal
government's consciousness on this issue
and he he's been laboring in that field
as Jerry how has been laboring as Josh
Lederberg has a lot of great Americans
and they did a lot of good the reason we
have some stockpiles of medicines today
that we can draw on in an emergency is
because these people helped make the
government aware of what the issues were
now bill Patrick like a lot of these
death and destruction scientists have an
undeniable black humor idiosyncrasies
and you can dismiss them as slightly
crazy and in some respects they are but
they
there was a hearing with a sprayer and
show hell yes I got a he he comes like
with a guy named his little tricks he's
terrifying
yeah yes and he's got a bag of anthrax
simulant n he shows people first of all
he shows how easy it is to get into
federal office buildings with all this
stuff or on airplanes and he had many
Senate hearings has pulled out his
sprayer and said I've just killed you
all place gets very quiet after II let
me ask you into since we know that it
might be easy to get it might be easy to
multiply it and so forth let me do you
need a bill Patrick under your roof to
take these kinds of germs and make them
very very very dangerous there's some
argument about that and I'm one of the
folks that believes that you can get to
a certain point in making a biological
agent deadly but getting it to the point
where you have the concentration of
spores that we saw in the Daschle letter
which was the ten to the twelfth or so
per ml I mean it was very concentrated
material where you've got the
electrostatic charge removed where
you've got preservatives where you've
got it
milled down to under a micron so it gets
into the lungs I don't believe that you
know the Ted Kaczynski kind of homegrown
terrorists would do that I think they
could get to a point and I think they
could make a deadly anthrax but to get
it to the level that we're seeing now I
just I'm not one of the people that
subscribe
what about let's switch germs and and
since we've just had the experience of
watching 19 people die wittingly or no
in those airplanes if I could convince
if I were running some terrorist
organization and could convince someone
to
become a smallpox carrier then I
wouldn't need bill Patrick I wouldn't
need any fabricators I could just walk
him into this room and he could sit and
sit here right I mean so the entry
levels are doing something really
disastrous could be very very yeah we've
had a debate about that da Henderson who
is probably the world's leading expert
on smallpox as again there's a debate
about whether that would work or not you
might look a little ugly because you
know by the time you get to the point
with smallpox that you're contagious you
are very very sick when you get to the
ninth or 10th day following the exposure
and you are contagious you are extremely
sick and whether or not you'd be able to
walk around most people at that point
are a really bedridden could it happen
absolutely but you know and the notion
of contaminating people overseas putting
them on a plane sending into a couple
cities and you know one case of smallpox
in New York City is a public health
nightmare so if if we had one person
that had the strength to get out to ride
the subways or go into a theater like
this or if it wouldn't such a person be
if the president keeps asking us to be
aware if we all saw what it looks like
to have smallpox we would recognize such
a person and because you would throw a
towel on and yes no you know it depends
on you know makeup covering you know in
the winter people wear scarves and
smallpox is spread through droplets
through coughing and it could be done
you wouldn't have to be a martyr I mean
you you know all you need is a little
atomizer and running around and I mean I
don't want to you know give anybody
ideas but you know you don't you don't
have to be infected and let's forget it
to get it around that way let me switch
those things you say that's a second
theme which is actually a very
interesting theme in the book which
suggests obliquely really that that the
that the world may be at a very
dangerous
right now because of the nature of war
and that offensive weapons should never
get too far ahead of defensive weapons
or everything gets very unstable so iron
is introduced and bronze shields no
longer work or gunpowder Trump's armor
or horses and cavalry Trump infantry are
we at a stage now where weapons are
being created for which there are no
defenses temporarily and so we're all
exposed anyone well back up one step and
look at the motivations we have a kind
of at least for the moment a one
superpower world in which in the area of
conventional weaponry you could say the
United States really has an almost you
know overwhelming advantage so this
gives an incentive I think on the other
side to look for something else and one
can I mean I think it'd be a fair
statement right bill one can create
weapons right now for against which
there is no defense as a possibility
that whether it's been done or not no
it's more than that it has been done the
Soviet Union did I mean the difference
between the Soviet program and the
American program was that the Soviets
made weapons against which there was no
defense so you know whereas the United
States never weaponized smallpox the
Soviet Union had a hundred metric tons
of the stuff no that's a fascinating in
the book you'd you describe the United
States from the press in the United
States President Nixon says let's not
we're not gonna make any more biological
weapons and everybody says neither will
be everybody signs these things and the
Russians go ahead and bill Patrick calls
these the old emojis the old moldy czar
plague smallpox Marburg and anthrax why
did the Russians make such gigantic
volumes of these traditional germs what
what do they do that for well I kept
asking
former Soviet scientists that when I
would visit these facilities you know
why so much why these agents against
which there is no vaccine and there is
no antibiotic that works in many cases
and they would just look at me and say
well because we thought you were doing
it and I said but well you know we
signed the treaty and they would say to
me well so did we and I said well but
why you so much I mean when Andy Weber
and I said when I write about in the
book visit step divorce this is a plant
which is has the production building
which is fabulous is too good a story
this is too good a stir
Andy Weber who's actually sitting
amongst us tonight is an amazing
character in his book first of all who
is he well I don't know he's too modest
to be shown he's here but who is he he
is a pentagon official who works for a
program called Cooperative Threat
Reduction which was a very inspired and
effective program aimed at finding the
former Soviet scientists who used to
work even before that who what he was a
Georgetown kid at Georgetown University
students yes
learning Russian fluent Russian who
served in the Arab world and spoke
Arabic was in Saudi Arabia during the
Gulf War switched over to learn Russian
and learn Russian goes to Kazakhstan
served in the embassy there used to go
hunting with Caza officials now here's
the thing he's a foreign service officer
he's in Kazakhstan all the other foreign
service officers I guess we're living in
the Foreign Service officer's building
yes and and he goes he gets his own
apartment has a three-legged pitbull
named Maggie and decides to go lunch
with the boys in this case with the
kazakh boys yes big he's hunting then
some guy says hey
want to see step the gorse so reads what
is step the course step the course was
one of the few standby production plants
giant facilities outside of Russia the
heartland it was in Kazakhstan and that
made it unusual because normally the
Russians wanted to keep this stuff
inside had any American ever been to
this place never and Andy Weber talked
his way in and went with a team of
Americans and visited it and told me
afterwards that I just had to see it
because I wouldn't believe it and I went
there about two years after he did when
Indy arrives though there's a guy named
go Noddy
so Grenada let your screen is the
colonel he's in charge of this place
this is a huge complex with gigantic
fertilizing things and God knows what
two football fields long ten fermenters
each one of one just one of these ten
could have held the entire Iraqi bio
warfare program so this is and this is
one of six facilities like this in the
former Soviet era so this one facility
probably makes enough germs to kill all
human beings yes if the order came
that's what would happen in the meantime
it was just kind of testing and making
batches to see if they were to drop away
any somehow it gets an invitation from
the president of the country to go to
this place and he is very persuasive
is it the pit bull or in I didn't have
the pleasure of meeting the pit bull
though they were still talking about the
pit bull club in Kazakhstan when I got
there well the three legs it was chance
for the imagination to wonderful so the
novel approach can meet sandy at the
front of this place and says get out of
here
yes it does not love at first sight what
are you doing in my city what are you
here for and he says well actually I'm
here at the invitation of the president
and the defense minister and blip your
skin is having none
doesn't believe it and Andy has to make
a call to the Capitol and get faxes and
finally will not leave he just will not
go away gets in and by the end of the
day for some mysterious reason Grenada
has him home and starts with the
serenading cocker spaniel and stressed
to sing to him yes chase I think it must
have been a dog thing
but when osterlich Yoshi and had this
fantastic singing dog chase it would
sing along to these Russian ballads and
I this I saw myself so I know it's
triple and they kind of bonded you know
Andy Weber was not judgmental he
understood what was at stake and I think
all of the people in this program who
worked so hard to build these contacts
and relationships had to be had to
suspend judgment so that the main
project now the goal of this program was
to link up with these Russians and and
other former Soviet scientists to find
out where they are what they were
working on what they're doing now and
whom they're doing it for and that is
what the Cooperative Threat Reduction
program is all about and it does it so
successfully that the United States now
has a pretty good idea of who is where
and what they are working on thanks to
this open aboveboard non covert program
which was underfunded and has been
underfunded since its existence it is an
amazing program and the people who do it
thank you Andy have done us all a
tremendous service is it safe it is
amazing
Andy and granada's friendship and the
dogs and all create a a and intelligence
bonanza so bill we now discover step by
step that the man who ran this place can
all avec defects the United States he
starts talking about it and it turns out
that the Russians are not content just
to make lots of germs they're making new
versions of germs using recombinant DNA
technology who is so gay papa
Sergei is one of the the creative
recombinant by bio engineers and
scientists that did genetic engineering
on bugs on bad bugs to make them even
worse he worked at places like vector
and obolensky and it's really a
mind-boggling kind of pursuit that these
guys were into but he would take
something we talked about in the book
having taken a relatively mild bug the
bug that causes Legionnaires disease
Legionella and you know with the wonders
of biotechnology and genetic engineering
they were able to take some of the genes
from the human body and put them into
this bug and be able to have this bug
trigger in effect what is a quick
multiple sclerosis in in people that
would get infected with it so that you'd
have this an immune response the immune
system would start to destroy itself and
they tested these little bugs on I think
it was guinea pigs and mice and they
were walking up the up the ladder
getting ready to test them on primates
when the program fell apart what
possible reason would you have to create
or you know enhance the sonic plague or
why would they do that the you know I
can't answer that question for myself in
the case of like that kind of germ a
super Legionella but the the one thing
that makes if you can make sense out of
this black art at all the idea of
creating bugs that can outwit cures you
know a an anthrax that you can outwit an
antibiotic or can get around a vaccine
our government worries about this right
now the Pentagon is doing its own
bioengineering of a Russian designer
anthrax to make sure that it can't
outwit our anthrax vaccine so they're
Syria serious measure countermeasures
it's a little bit of a biological arms
race where you start to envision you
know step counter step move counter move
is this in some degree a reflection of
the claims of personalities that do this
sort of work you have Sergei today is in
Virginia and he says to you that he's
still kicked even though he's now
working the other side of the game you
know he still can't stop imagining new
designs yeah he definitely they are
there is this scientific fascination
with the possible and you even see it in
the likes of Robert Oppenheimer you know
with the idea that's so technically
sweet for the h-bomb that he just really
wants to you know go with it and see you
know whether it can be done and you see
you see this a lot now Sergei is a smart
guy and he's trying to wake up the most
what about them or the human instinct
they but there's a character in booking
in Berlin who's a you yeah who knows his
germ lines from A to Z and then someone
says you know remember when the
Americans were taken hostage in Iran for
months and it was a world crisis right
and this man didn't know
except his chance right right well I
think they that's the way the Soviet
Union wanted it less than that she who
was the head of what a wonderfully named
institutions vector right which which
specialized in smallpox and viruses
turning them into weapons and levers out
in the middle of Siberia it is a long
slept ladies and gentlemen to get there
I can assure you and once again Andy
Weber was out talking to Lev this time
Lev's and archaea was making one of his
first trips to to Virginia to the United
States and they discussed and he was
trying to explain to him why it was that
the Americans were so sensitive about it
ran why we didn't want the Russians
providing technology dangerous
technology to Iran and he would say you
know love when when our people were
taken hostage are you we all remember
that he hadn't a clue he had never been
told and this is a man who's a very
senior in was very senior in the Soviet
you say there's a sort of thing but you
know Bill Patrick's our ongoing tells
bill I guess that many of these people
are I mean scientists by nature I would
you know this is gonna be a one of those
wild generalizations which is obviously
wrong but many of them tend to be
apolitical and there are I mean we know
from his words from a given or bill says
to you you know we never connected to
this to people he said yes it's a people
maybe that's bad I'm looking at this
movie right it was it was designed to be
impersonal I mean they did everything in
their power to just you know to produce
the product and they do it you know in
with biological arms and chemicals and
nukes I mean you name it their own
people were falling ill as the weapons
scientists themselves were sometimes
infected and still it didn't quite I
think we're sort of forget it clone sex
a follicular that I think we're
forgetting a context which is that
before 1989 a lot of people viewed the
competition between East and West as you
know a very serious thing when you when
you press these people and we they
always felt the same way as you do wait
a minute you wanted to do what was your
entire life I figure out how to kill
people
what were they think what were they
thinking think I think I'm sorry go
ahead when I want to get back when the
bill was later these weapons and if you
talk with him
bill was making these and in the fifties
and sixties when we were in the middle
of this arms race and and the threat of
war was very real and being the the good
American that bill was they were looking
bill builted disconnected he you know
they go out to Doug Wayne and they would
look for ways to make it a finer to
aerosolize it better to lay it down
better they looked at the meteorology to
see what type of environment was best to
to use it in and they had this all
worked out and they viewed it much like
any other weapon it was a weapons system
to them it was there to protect the
country it was there in response and as
horrific as these things are now back
then that they were viewed as part of
the Arsenal that this country had bill
let me talk about it in reverse let's
talk about the defense's because people
who made them had to of course imagine
that they might be used against their
country so they have to try to figure
out how to defend against them which
gets back to this theme do we have
offensive weapons for which there is no
defense the one horse problem comes to
mind before the Gulf War bill we decided
oh maybe Sodom Hussein may come at us
with anthrax so we thought we'd better
get some anthrax vaccines up and then
came the one horse problem what is this
I mean I'm gonna defer to Steve this is
his an expert on the horse on the horse
first flight his name was yes well I
mean it's actually on anthrax vaccine I
learned this this is not a toxin
which was actually useful thing to have
you've been you've tari you've gotten
the disease and you can give somebody a
medicine which will you know stop those
disease from killing you we clearly did
not believe in the American military the
American military did not believe
notwithstanding these various reports
about anthrax being shipped here there
and everywhere they did not believe this
is going to happen to them and so not
only do we only have the one horse to
explain this that is the antidote to
botulism I guess as you go to a horse is
it bachelors and boxes yes and you go to
a horse which has been exposed to this
disease you get some blood from the
horse the horse has done something
I guess it's good then you take the
blood from the horse and then you go to
make medicines against the tides right
so we had one horse that's right one
horse right there was a famous Pentagon
briefing where a guy came into the the
Colt the tank where the Chiefs of the
various military services gathered he
won't explain exactly what the situation
was visa via the Iraqi bio program he
put a picture of the horse up on a giant
easel and he said ladies and gentlemen
that's the industrial base for our
biological defense program a slight
exaggeration but he made his point they
also didn't have the anthrax vaccine on
hand they they had enough to cover you
know well they were starting to order
enough to cover a hundred thousand
soldiers they sent five hundred thousand
the Gulf so you can figure out what the
problem was and they never resolved us
they haven't in fact resolved it to this
day
Oh John let me ask you it Jerry is it
rights to say that we're now at a time
in history where there will be weapons
coming online available to various
belligerents for which we can't really
produce the NT the cure or the vaccine
quick enough that is there's going to be
now a lag they'll have stuff we'll have
to go to our horse and wait for the
horse you know and so yes we're we're
accelerating the smallpox vaccine
program quite significantly we right now
we've only got fifteen point four
million doses of smallpox vaccine stored
in the United States if in fact we
needed it
today we could dilute it at five-to-one
and have roughly 70 77 million doses but
that that's clearly you know if we have
multiple cities that might or might not
be enough we just don't know there are
acid that's anthrax which we've heard of
no that's more smallpox I'm sorry what
about when the one of those descriptions
is a what if pop-ups wasn't was a
medicine that would make you so joyous
remember this one what a jewel you'd die
of joy it was they worked on a number of
they worked on a number of bio
modulators some that would cause
depression some that would cause low
blood pressure they worked on some
things that just worked on various parts
of the the physiology of how do you
design a defense against something you
haven't seen yet well it's very
difficult very very difficult you know
DARPA is spending a lot of money on
innovative you know broad-spectrum
things you know God's specific immunity
and there are there's what you're going
after the immune system or something
that is immuno regulated that's fine
when you're going something after
something that goes after that is not
bacterial or viral or a toxin where you
go after the physiology of the organism
then what you have to do is basically
treat symptoms and if you recognize them
if you recognize what about that's the
other problem detection in the in the
Gulf War we didn't know how to detect
even diseases we had heard of we've got
now something this was the it was an
anthrax detector that didn't work too
well but now Lawrence Livermore has come
up with a handheld one do these work
the no no there's a new one that the
Mayo Clinic is field testing one right
now
there's been a host of biological
detectors that about been out there I've
been getting calls for five or six years
and you know these snake oil salesmen
are out there
want to sell you these detectors to put
in the office building air handling
systems for people to do home tests and
they stay actually four years ago DoD
gave out these little things called
smart tickets to all the cities in the
countries to all the fire departments
and they just don't work the false
positives were this one agent that they
eluded to bacillus thuringiensis which
is a larvacide and if you grind this up
and it gives you a false positive for
anthrax you could also miss anthrax
smart tickets have now come out with a
second generation that they say is
better CDC at this point it's not
recommending any of these I think within
the next six months to a year though we
will see some kind of an immuno asset
that does detect anthrax either in the
environment or in patients it's going to
be very important that we're able to
detect in humans exposure to anthrax
very quickly we just don't have that now
well Your Honor I was going to ask you a
bunch of other things let me just so I
get questions I'm gonna run to the end
let's talk a little bit about them some
hope seems to be running out the window
here there is there are some solutions
one of them is been is to really look at
the public health system as a whole
stiva the public health system right now
according to you guys have half of them
have no email twenty percent of them
still have rotary phones I'm not sure as
of when but isn't there some movement
sort of a broad and growing movement to
address as a defense matter like we used
to do with highways say that all these
community hospitals and all of the
ability of people doctors everywhere to
talk to other doctors everywhere quickly
is a first-line defense at this point
well it's amazing how things have
changed after September 11th I mean you
know the whole sort of emphasis in the
area of health was cutbacks reductions
you know
mergers of hospitals and other
profit-making hospitals but yes
absolutely and the arguments I really
like to turn this over to Jerry because
he lives in breezed it's but I mean the
simple argument is that this is a
no-brainer you improve your public
health system and if you have an
outbreak of normal disease you're better
off and if you have an outbreak of
abnormal disease you're better off right
I mean this is so simple this the public
health infrastructure in this country
has been deteriorating for twenty
twenty-five years public health
particularly after September 11th is the
national security issue now but you know
we've been monitoring I mean you can do
this very cheaply and very easily we've
been doing this in New York City for
almost five years now where there are a
series of health indicators that allow
you to monitor the health of the
community so you can
there's a guy out at Sandy Al's Ella
cough who's done a wonderful job of
developing a system that allows you to
overlay all this data on a map so you
can look for aberrant patterns of
disease in the community which means
what you know who's coming through the
door with what at the end of every day
yeah you can do it on an hour an hour
basis where you look at EMM emergency
medical service calls deaths sick calls
you can look at can you do it if you
don't have a computer in any hospital no
you do it if you don't have a button we
have really realized what if what has to
be rebuilt and that's part of what the
Department of Health and Human Services
is trying to get done this is not going
to happen overnight we've got health
department's around the country that
have spent their whole life working 9:00
to 5:00 you know no emergency numbers at
night and not responsive to these types
of things it's going to take some time
to rebuild the public health
infrastructure but we've got to do it
and here's you know it's one thing to
talk about yes we understand you got it
you know Public Health that's the mantra
now it's another thing to put your money
where your mouth is and Jerry's too
modest to say this but part of the
reason New York is in such good shape
relative to most
is that he and Marcie Layton and the
Health Department and a few other really
inspired dedicated people worked night
and day to push push push to get money
for the city for these kinds of
Emergency Services and Public Health
Department but now even after September
11th and even after anthrax the
administration's bill that has gotten is
working its way through Congress only
provides for a hundred and thirty
million dollars extra to rebuild this
massive dilapidated infrastructure now
that is not serious
that is rhetoric that's not a serious
commitment talk about something that the
administration would feel more
comfortable about they the DARPA which
is the this division of the Defense
Department that does very out-there
research has been looking around in the
private sector and one of you guys what
are the two you described a company
really interesting to me called Maxo Jim
what do they do they they have this
astonishing technique to be able to kind
of do artificial evolution at a
molecular level and come up with very
quick responses you know in a petri dish
you know in selecting for different
kinds of adding antibiotic resistance or
building in different kinds of being
able to come up very rapidly to evolve
new kinds of cures for various bugs
there's one where the soap industry has
detergency for years have been trying to
figure out how to remove grass stain
right right right right
good laundry yeah enzymes these advanced
proteins that they can come up with real
quick they make on the commercial side a
better tide on the biological defense
side they can come up with a better
antibiotic and they and we can do a
process you've called DNA shuffling what
does that mean you you you you break the
DNA or you take DNA from like 20 30 40
different strains and you take them and
you mix them together and just by rote
you are able to
kind of do a very quick trial on the air
testing to see what works and what
doesn't you don't need a master plan you
kind of do it in the lab and see what
works and you do it very quickly and in
large volume and you it's almost
miraculous how fast you can come up with
novel compounds that can have very
powerful activity so the happy thought
that I was having her though was reading
this part of book was you're standing on
34th Street at in comes some new dread
disease and you watch six people turn
blue and pink or whatever and while
they're doing that some sniffer goes and
hands it off to this company and they do
a quick gene shuffle and they come up
instantly with a spray that will
counteract the spray that's getting on
you know slow that happy dream down to
something more reasonable is that a
general idea it's a fast response we
shuffle way way out there yeah
biological arms race people are
definitely talking about that as a as a
thought yes absolutely but by you know
we should also remember too that before
we walk too far down that road that just
as Jerry was saying with the Oldham
oldies this stuff ain't easy and really
I think that you know we shouldn't worry
too much about the far future because a
lot of times you make these superbugs
and you get them out in the environment
and they die I mean they look perfectly
reasonable on a petri dish but you get
them out in the jungle of all the
bacteria that are out there on this
floor and on our bodies and everywhere
else and they can't compete yeah there's
all that's an important issue because
you know and in a canal OPEC has talked
about how they tried splicing Ebola and
smallpox to make a more lethal weapon
and at the end of the day if most of the
folks that I deal with think it in fact
it might attenuate it and not be quite
as lethal and we we do know that a bola
when it gets in the afire environment
dies very quickly as as do some of the
other viruses so we've got to keep this
balance we've got to keep it in
perspective because while some of this
stuff has been weaponized you know once
you release it into the
it is not it does not survive very well
some of it does you know anthrax the
spores from anthrax can stay around
forever they get into the soil they get
into the building and they'll be around
for 50 or 60 years smallpox is a virus
that is very resilient it's it does not
deteriorate some of these others though
and some of these outliers do not
survive well in the environment I worry
about like what about a flu
I mean flu oh absolutely it's very good
point I mean that you know the flu
pandemic of 1918 killed millions and
millions of people in this country
there's somebody taking something like
the flu you're absolutely right but then
you get up with this confront the
problem of dropping the file cabinet on
your own foot you know if you let
something like that loose it's good you
know you know sama bin Laden has mother
and who he calls before the attack and
you know you have to be careful when you
mess around with this stuff but I'm
gonna conclude our formal push this by
just reading the nicest statistic in
your book from something called the
Monterey Institute of International
Studies whoever they are in the 285
incidents since 1976 involving some form
of germ warfare or germs 44 percent of
them caused no harm at all that was no
clear harm 76 percent hurt only five
people or less and in some of these
cases like in Japan they just kept
trying and trying and trying and had to
switch to chemicals before anything
worked so there's statistics that leads
up to know on our side now I can go to
the questions this question begins side
one oh I have an infection control nurse
at a large University affiliated
hospitals scrambling to prepare for
covert as in source unknown organism
unknown and over to know an organism in
need of men and how can I do
surveillance of all pts is all points in
clinics and in emergency rooms for
bioterrorism and still do all my other
activities effectively I'm doing
homeland bio warfare defense I need help
daily inside the hospital shouldn't this
be federally funded
actually there there's a movement to try
and get funding for hospitals and is
this Judy's point that we need more
money for hospitals because the
infection control folks at the
hospital's infection control nurses the
ID Doc's can't pick up all this work we
do we need to automate the hospitals
that'll make it easier for the
infections can infection control folks
but there needs to be somebody at the
hospital whose role it is is to look
broadly at what's going on with these
issues and to be able to feed data into
the public with the local public health
department and again we need money to do
this and it's gonna take some time
between the two trends have sort of
worries about bio defense and where
healthcare is going because more and
more hospitals or profit-making ventures
the great trend American profit-making
ventures is to cut your inventory you
don't want a lot of stuff hanging around
you paid for because that doesn't help
you make a profit
well it's exact opposite of what you
want for bio defense which is plenty of
inventory in case something bad happens
clear the federal government is gonna
have to step in and make up for that
well here's a contrary notion from
someone in the audience if the United
States public relations machinery can
create con man effector consent so
modern thinkers say couldn't the US also
manufacture a bioterrorist enemy the
suggestion here is that the messengers
are panicking and that the message is
that perhaps not as scary as we here are
making it a little it's a
misinterpretation I'll read it again if
the US PR machine can manufacture
consent and the u.s. also manufacture a
bioterrorist enemy so let me see if I
can understand the question are we
fabricating the threat hastler or are we
pulling it out of proportion you know
that's that's one of the issues we had
to confront for the last five or six
years I think that for those of us that
are in this business and
you know the certainly the four of us
here that have worked on this when you
look at the facts you look at where some
of the Russian scientists have gone you
look at the fact that we don't know
where all the stockpiles when they left
Russia did they take some of the seat
culture with them are they manufacturing
this stuff elsewhere can it fall into
other hands you know the the probability
has certainly grown prior to September
11th the probability of the use of the
biological weapon was pretty low but the
impact is so significant that it's
something we simply cannot ignore it's
something like smallpox if it worked and
God forbid it was ever used would would
be a devastating type of an incident so
you know we have to balance how we run
around trying to get people's attention
on this but you know I you know there
are some people that like getting on TV
and talking about the sky falling
there's also a group that has been
quietly just going about talking to
Congress briefing the president briefing
agency heads and trying to get attention
to this issue and in what I think's been
a fairly responsible fashion although I
noticed that even the president United
States this is President Clinton in your
book gets quite exercised because he
reads a very scary novel
and the very scary novel is in fact a
sort of a plot in a way I mean the guy
who writes it a guy named Preston is is
put on to writing it by people who have
an agenda so there is a sense that you
use alarm in order to get results and
here was the president United States
being quite effectively alarmed by a
whole story I think this debate has
changed somewhat after the anthrax
letters and after September 11th I mean
I was I guess of the three of us always
kind of Chicken Little
you know I really did think the sky
all one day because I had lived and
worked in the Middle East and knew how
hard some of these militant groups were
trying to get their hands on any kind of
weapon of mass destruction that they
could use against the old powerful Great
Satan and I never for a moment doubted
that if they succeeded in getting these
weapons and buying themselves a former
Soviet scientist that they would use
what they had so we used to have fierce
debates about this but I came at it very
much alarmed and persuaded that the
weapons could and should be used and
that fear and concern that I had was
reinforced by my trips to the former
Soviet facilities they were terrified I
should ask you as long as you're sitting
here what was it like to open up that
letter when the Tucker powder that you
didn't know his fellow interview well
let's put it this way it wasn't wasn't a
great day okay the only happiness was
the end of it it just shows have you got
the leather you were on the phone to
someone at NBC or something no no I was
on the phone actually with yes I learned
at the time that the powder was kind of
sitting on me that someone called me
from NBC saying have you heard what's
happened here and I'm sitting there
saying I'll get back to you so what did
you do by the way you got it from your
chairman did you I thought that the
three of us certainly the four of us
that we've been trained we know what to
do and when it really happens you forget
a lot of that trades very very quickly I
can assure you because I I did the right
things but my colleague what did you do
well I decided I would get the powder
off of me so I went to the ladies room
which is fortunately right near my desk
and washed it off and it wasn't it on
your spirit is on my
pants and I've gotten kind of you know
it had gone to my face and my clothing
was all over so and it was around me and
that's where we made a mistake because
colleagues everywhere people rush to
someone's assistance and colleagues came
to me saying are you all right are you
all right and of course that's the last
thing they should have done they should
have stayed away from me and I should
have been kept away from them because
the closer they came to the powder near
my desk the more in danger they were so
we wound up for the situation in which
20 people were taking cipro at the New
York Times until we discovered that it
wasn't in fact anthrax it was just
whatever it was and since you were the
sky of falling lady you must have been
really enough I don't know if I didn't
think it was anthrax I never really knew
about her what she called me she said
she said I don't think this is real she
was actually very calm in the moment
yeah well said I think it's Al Capone
you know it's interesting Jerry when I
will you roll the movie back to that
moment you look at the advice you were
given what we now know it was all wrong
in point of fact one of the things
people said to us was said judy is it
white you suggest it's white they said
well if it's white and dusting it's
certainly not gonna be and we now know
from - the letter it certainly goes
absolutely and you know when we was
describers having roughly fallen to the
floor New York Health Department said
well if it fell on the floor I guess we
can all just walk around this building
and again had the - a letter come to us
the outcome would have been very very
very unfortunate I'd like to come back
to this question about the exaggeration
because I think it's very important and
it's it's something that happened among
us as authors I was probably the most
skeptical going into this and really
professionally all of us are trained
skeptics by virtue of the journalism
that we do but we also had a lot of
experience with the military and with
threat inflation I mean the Pentagon
mastered the art of building up the comi
giant right to build its budgets and do
all that stuff
and we what you know knowing all this
and knowing that history we walked into
this deeper and deeper and got more and
more concerned as you look at the
evidence and the unanswered questions
and not knowing where those good
hard-working Soviet scientists are some
of whom are like Sergei Popov certainly
at that point we got seriously concerned
and wrote this book in fairness though I
will say if the letters had not been
sent you know we may will not be sitting
here first we'll cuz no would have ever
read the book assuming that that was a
case that people had read it and bought
it for some reason I think that there
would have been a substantial group of
people who would have said and they
would have had an argument that this
book is alarmist that in point of fact
not since the rise reaches there is
anything happened that you're off on the
wrong track here terrorists do
conventional kinds of things they do
truck bombs car bombs the airplane and
bomb really is a variation on a theme
that we've seen and in fact you guys are
deflecting us from doing what we should
be doing which is defending against
conventional terrorism all those
arguments I think would have had some
merit well we can't at least I can maybe
judy has a crystal ball we can't pretend
to be able to say we predicted the
future we just sort of took the trend
lines and drew them out and toured the
horizons at at some point these things
are gonna cross well here's a variation
on the question is there any sense of
what countries and individuals who might
use these weapons consider their effect
on third world countries when it spreads
it does raise the question why didn't
Saddam Hussein use some of the liquid
stuff that he had all he did he did he
used both chemical weapons and biologics
and hwacha he killed oh you know not on
us on Americans oh he uses all these old
people and he you know there is a
history there using it so but this is an
important issue I think when you look at
something highly contagious like
smallpox because if it got loose you
know you have a possibility of a global
epidemic that would hurt the developing
world more than it would hurt
where we do have medical care and convex
need quickly and try to cordon this
thing off but you know there's a there's
a strong you know built-in disincentive
to let something absolutely wildly
contagious like that loose here's the OP
the the Union to that yeah how likely is
it that we would use biological or
chemical weapons against against Osama
bin Laden or can a no tell if there's
any chance that we would first of all
but we don't have stockpiles of
biological weapons anymore
we do have chemical weapons stockpile in
eight locations in the United States and
those are all targeted for destruction
in one way or another there by by and
large most of what's left our
organophosphates and it is never over
our not now I don't think we would ever
first of all the basic genie in the book
describes the United States of America
in 1962 with mister bill Patrick
reporting saying the United States was
was seriously considering I don't know
how seriously poisoning the people of
Cuba so that when we during the Cuban
Missile Crisis that we could neutralize
them for up for a period of weeks and he
said only 2% of them would die old folks
like me said Bill you do the math two
percent of Cuba would be about a hundred
and forty thousand dead people now I
don't know whether that was US policy
but apparently had come onto the table
at some point in our own nation we were
gonna use Q fever and tularemia a
mixture they would get they had a
cocktail ready of Q and tularemia T uses
in Cuba I think in the current
environment first of all we don't have
the biological weapons anymore we do
have some chemical weapons but most of
the Marron not in condition that could
be used the law and again you guys
answer this but from my perspective the
likelihood of us ever using a chemical
weapon in an offensive fashion it almost
non-existent this all comes up by the
way at a moment when first of all it's
before these weapons in the band
everybody's doing it and I do not myself
personally believe
that we would have does anybody
seriously the top the Kennedy
administration was about to you know
drop tularemia on Cuba I don't know dude
you do you have a that they you know the
these were boys with toys to a large
extent out there cooking up wild stuff
well it it was a serious war plan I mean
it got you a fairly serious a high seats
sufficiently high level that we thought
it important enough to put in our book
and the fact that that program and that
plan is still secret to this day I think
raises some questions but for me the
dividing line was really that great
peacenik Richard Nixon who drew the line
paradox of paradoxes and said after 1969
no the United States were announces this
weapon this whole class of weapons we
will not use these we will abandon them
and that is something that the United
States has sought to and as far as I
know no one has ever alleged seriously
with any credibility that we are engaged
in offensive original opening
observation it's not really in our
interest I mean these weapons don't work
well for military ops they don't work
well on a battlefield they're perfect
terrorists here's my second to last
question I guess from the audience early
in the course of the current terrorist
activities cases of anthrax infection
were misdiagnosed
so therefore seems possible that anthrax
deaths in the past were never diagnosed
as such question is it all likely that
some of the recent anthrax deaths deaths
by the result of contamination from
normal activities and not from terrorist
strikes I I don't think so unless you're
out there sniffing the dirt because
there is some anthrax that that
livestock that animal animals get but
the cases of anthrax in this country are
really few and foreign in between and I
don't think especially at this point
when people have been on
that cases have been misdiagnosed but
somebody missed so many postal workers
in these particular plays of a
particular Larry's win have been
afflicted tells you a fair amount this
is not a coincidence
who has the technology to mill anthrax
bacilli to improve air Salling and what
is the current state of recombinant DNA
research to combine viruses and improve
delivery and speed we've talked about
bee but who does have the tech the
technology
unfortunately it's it's widely widely
available it's my impression we've been
doing web searches and it's this these
powders fine powders are used everywhere
in our economy I mean you have them in
when you make a floppy disk and you want
to be able to put down a fine a spray of
magnetic particles when you make when
you have a laser printer going back and
forth and you need finally a fine mist
of all that kind of stuff I mean in
pharmaceuticals
you know you're constantly milling fine
powders down to the 5 micron size
perfect example my one of them I know
one of my children has asthma and
there's a wonderful new invention
instead of having to use a sort of
little device just brace up for 10
minutes it just as a little powder that
you inhale and it's a respirable level
you know obviously 5 micron things of
this is being made by a pharmaceutical
cup it works very nicely let me conclude
by asking you to try to look on the
bright side of this if there is well if
if the two central tenants of the book
seemed very dangerous to me one is that
we are at a very very dangerous time
because new weapons are arriving for
which we cannot detect cannot anticipate
and cannot defend against temporarily
I'm hoping and B there are many many
more players in the game of big-time
warfare because of these technologies
then how long a period of time are we so
what what what when will this end what
has to happen and arguably this just
could go on and on and on well I don't
think it ends but I you know when people
say well gee how do you sleep at night
how do you guys sleep at night
I think the answer to the question is
this is not like nuclear weapons
this is bio defense is possible and it's
a question of money and will and
commitment
unlike nuclear weapons where we all
remember are some of us in this audience
Duck and Cover which was pointless and
ridiculous there are so many things you
can do in this area if a society has the
will from training your doctors and
nurses and pharmacists to recognize
these diseases when they see them to
getting Internet in every public health
office to funding the kind of work that
Steve and and Jerry and Bill have been
talking about I mean we can do something
which is really why I wanted to write
this book the other thing is that this I
think we're it's a wonderful moment in
time because to really say we've
witnessed weapons of mass pandemonium or
disruption not mass destruction and
really using this stuff developing it in
quantity and being able to produce mass
death is not easy to do you know you
can't the crop-dusting with anthrax is
not easy and attacking a large city with
a crop duster is not easy there's many
many many technical steps and in a way
this is a beautiful moment because if I
could use this metaphor we've kind of
gotten an immunization with these
attacks and you know the us immune
system is getting stronger now
and it can understand you know work
better against the things that are good
that are could arise in the future
because people are getting smarter the
information is getting out the
technology keeps marching forward but
it's hard to do and that's that gives us
some time I agree I think this was a
wake-up call and I think that this is
the time that we really need to to
engage people in this issue and as Judy
said it's gonna take a financial
commitment there we've got to get the
good science out there
and it it's all doable is that this can
all be addressed that the risk is not
that great but the impact is so
significant that we can't ignore it I've
said that already we really have to make
the commitment and this hopefully is the
wake-up call that gets the Congress
focused on this and I know the Secretary
of Health has been very engaged to this
and since he took over and it has been
trying to refocus effort but but it's
going to take a financial commitment as
well well I'll just say in concluding
that one of the things that the book
taught me is that every so often you
find in the midst of a very very dark
situation you find somebody who's sort
of lights the way this fellow Andy Weber
who is here did over and over again in
these very weird circumstances address
our traditional enemies the Russians
people who are actually in the process
of building weapons to destroy us in
very ugly ways and something in his
heart allowed him to sit down with these
apparently very bad people and address
them human to human and they responded
in the most amazingly human way so if
you read the book or if you just breathe
in deep because Andy's in the room so
what he's exhaling you could inhale it
is a a brilliant silver lining to a very
dark cloud so you know who you are and
thank you very much and thank you all
I guess be more yeah yes